what is going on there reject nation
greg here today i'm about to check out
the movie prey a film i'm very much
excited for i'm a big fan of the
predator franchise i like the movie 10
cloverfield lane which is the same
director couple of things i got to
acknowledge yeah i am shooting this a
little bit early because i have an
interview to do with the director and a
couple members of the cast for this film
so that interview should already be up
on the channel before this one is
another quick disclaimer i've seen those
comments come in people assuming there's
this automatic bias of recommendation
just because we've talked to some of the
filmmakers or talent involved with the
movie let me refer you to our eternal's
reaction our mortal kombat reaction our
hawkeye reaction you'll see we were very
very much not shy to be harsh on our
criticism for those properties while we
still interview the talent so if i end
up not liking this i'll be honest with
you guys i just won't tell them that
i'll just focus on what i liked about it
when talking with them and yes i am
shooting this by myself right now
because john a few days ago he tested
positive for the diesel as i called it i
myself tested positive for it i still
have it right now but i i
just talked to john i'm definitely
feeling much better than him i'm healing
i'm a superhuman like i said i'm a
massive fan of the predator franchise
really looking forward to this if you
guys can leave a like be very much
appreciated also subscribe click that
notification bell get notified when we
got another movie reaction up here on
the channel full length reaction watch
alongs where you sync up with the time
code are available for our super sexy
rejects over at our patreon page become
a sexy reject today by checking out all
we got to offer over there lastly the
team at prepper thank you guys for
helping us out and down these highlights
would not be in the position we are
today if it wasn't for all you
let's get into action people
[Music]
a long time ago
it is said
a monster came here
beautiful opening shot
beautiful music so far
[Music]
that dog better not die
badass
i hope you guys watch this movie with
headphones because there's some
incredible sound design already
[Music]
oh
yeah who is this chick she is badass
no
oh what a bunch of [ __ ]
i swear the dog better not die
gonna has to use that
that trap on the predator
this morning in the sky
i saw a sign
the thunderbird
it's time i'm ready for my katamiya
you really think you're ready you want
to hunt something that's hunting you
you're gonna get exactly what you want
[Music]
this is such a great shot is that for
warchief's bad knee hmm
he's getting worse
you didn't put on
who taught you about orange tortilla
you
you'll have to use orange tootsia when
you're fighting against the predator go
get us some orange tutsia
such a good buildup
oh
[ __ ]
i'm really enjoying this movie's grip on
the atmosphere so much
don't worry you're gonna get to prove
yourself with the ultimate prey
hina a lion he took buoy you gotta find
him
this movie's already way better than
that shane black one
[Laughter]
what the [ __ ]
who invited you
she tracks well and if we find fuji
alive
she knows medicine that dude's got a
cool voice
[Music]
i hate snakes
that's a great shot though
kill that snake
what a cool perspective shot
i don't like animal deaths but some
reason snakes so the one the main thing
that i can handle you see that crushed
bone
that's lying scared
the cat that made it was big
if it bleeds we can kill it
god i love how like immediate and
pulsating this is
he's breathing
that's her
so much could kill him it won't kill him
just cool his blood
cool his blood
that will come in handy why is puji
alive
there's something that scared the cat
away from its den
i've got this we don't have time to
waste talking we need to get him home
my number
she's the only one being smart
or at least asking the smart questions
[Music]
she's great there's a lot of life behind
her eyes look
it could be bear tracks but that's a big
bear
and why was it on its hind legs and what
skin to snake like that we need to keep
moving no
i have to warn my brother
aren't you guys the slightest bit
curious
i love the use of the tribal drums like
captures that like a heartbeat in a way
i found tracks
and they were huge
i'm not frightened by a bear i don't
know what it was i've never seen
anything like it
or whatever it was we're in the cat's
den now
we have to deal with the first
you guys are too cool
when the lion comes
you tell that thing this is as far as
you go
no more
this is it
i'm really loving the main girl's
performance a lot it's there's so much
nuance happening with her expressions
this interest curiosity fear courage is
all like layered into one sense of body
language
when your brother comes back
he and i will find the lion
and kill him oh my god
[Laughter]
your brother carried you home what about
the lion
oh they went after it sorry i have to
find him
no you need to rest oh man they're all
gonna be dead by the morning
this is cool how it's capturing the
like the primal themes of
predator
there's a lot of dead animals
so he returned her
then went back out there
killed the lion
and came back with a lion this guy is
just as cool as me
we didn't do it
you're right
we didn't do it i did
you tried it you couldn't bring it home
don't you worry you're gonna have the
greatest opportunity to prove yourself
[Music]
i don't know why i get almost like a
sort of
like survival video game vibe it's not
exactly that but you kind of get the
impression of it
guys i'm telling you i found green blood
it doesn't mean anything shut up woman
[Music]
don't mess around with these animals
oh come on man
i'm hating this predator because of all
the animal kills
oh don't do a wolfie
[Music]
oh
man
oh
there are so many animal deaths to think
i almost had my friend andrew gordon
watch this movie with me
he can't he really can't add all animal
baths
nice yo-yo axe i wonder if she was
really doing that
please don't kill the dog
holy balls
[Laughter]
[Music]
oh man you better [ __ ] this predator up
i swear to god
yikes
there's something incredible sound
design in this film
wow what a hell of a shot
come on
[Music]
oh good thing you're covered in all that
mud i feel like they're just planting so
many seeds for the final battle
that bear's dead
great
goddammit
no
puppy
i'm hoping the predator gets to it
before the gets to the dog
nice
holy [ __ ] mom you're not gonna believe
what i just saw
[Music]
[ __ ] terrifying damn
[Music]
oh it's got him it's got the bear
there's some blood in its mouth bears
lee's putting up a fight
[Music]
see how pissed of the
oh my god it's like drenched in blood
yikes
it's like the invisible man on steroids
holy crap
there's such great use of setting in
this film like with the
all the man versus nature qualities to
it and
things you can get trapped in and just
your environments it's so well utilized
i'm really digging this movie a lot this
is really good
it's a really good [ __ ] what are you
doing here
looking for you your brother sent us to
bring you home i'm ready for them to not
believe a single thing she says i saw
what left those tracks it fought and
killed a bear with its hands easily how
come it didn't kill you
nice good for you good for you
damn this guy can't get one hit
you want to leave
oh my god
oh [ __ ]
just sick
just don't put a weapon in her hands yet
you need a leash for your weapon
don't talk all she's [ __ ] tough man
he's got your ass kicked
he did it guys
what do you think drove the possums our
way
here you're about to
about to suck some dick man
whoa
that's different
that would be a good time
gnarly
i'd just be shouting i told you so
oh my goodness oh my goodness
oh god here it is
[Music]
i don't believe you
again this [ __ ] music man
[Music]
the trailer moment
let's get some serious nipple chills
right now
we have him
no he has us
[Music]
that was a terrifying shot
[Music]
oh my god
oh great
oh here we go
if the predator hasn't used a gun yet
will they get a gun from these guys
oh good there's a whole
whole settlement here to slaughter for
the predator
you killed the buffalo
ah
what did you see you are come on cheers
they're kind of hunt for red october
ringing it right yeah okay
if you were smart you'd help us tell us
something like the last sacred point
oh no
[Applause]
are you hurt
oh they tried he's got a billy's car
[Laughter]
although i did that all stealthily it's
coming
wow
something almost demonic about it
you want to know how i killed that lion
your plan
you had it naru
you can see what i missed
i don't know that this thing can be
killed
if it bleeds
we can kill it
we can kill it
wow
wow
[Music]
yep
[Applause]
trap on his guy said
that was cool
[Laughter]
i don't know how you're gonna defeat
this thing man
it's like wonder woman on no man's land
losing his leg to be free
wait
not what are you doing nader
nada
stop
i'm smarter than a beaver
you really set it up like you're gonna
cut a limb off all right just go back to
your tribe and throw away all your
weapons
let's put your face right up and then
spit your face right up in it
[Music]
wow he didn't even want to waste his
time with them
[Music]
nice work
[Music]
damn
oh damn
queen that's a gritty ass
one take shot man sure there was like
one hidden cut in there
i think there's like just enough of like
early stage predator
you know what i mean the
the technology stuff but he also seems
to have like
kind of a larger quantity of weapons
too much
you put in the gunner three four times
it's okay
he just shoots her and the movie
what easy
hahaha
his blood is cold
you really get that feel of like this
ferocious man slash beast in that
predator suit
you done [ __ ] up man
i can't see it
cold blood
[Music]
i thought he was gonna step like on his
heart or something
[Music]
no
that hell no
oh my god thank god
[Music]
wow gross
sometimes it feels like video game
levels i love it
[Music]
there you go
hey
[Music]
oh pooh good shot
not too much
not too little
[Music]
nice man
oh cowardly predator this is as far as i
go
oh
i really like that guy it bumps me up i
think the way they've they've captured
the predator here feels like uh some
type of ferocious hybrid of man and
beast that arose from nature as opposed
to like an alien from
an alien from space
[Music]
what's she gonna do with him
oh my goodness
you bled my brother
so now you bleed
[Music]
you can't see but i'm killing you
and it won't either
man you become a cold-hearted badass
that's what happens when your brother
dies
the predator is legit scary in this
nice work
nice
oh we hit a predator finale
oh [ __ ] is this like snowing or is it
just flowers falling
cool
i love it i love the look of it
yes and the cold breath ah i love it
nice nice
damn this player just got some parkour
skills man
[Music]
oh my god
oh my god
[Music]
harley
i love the aesthetics here
[Music]
he's got the axe in this
[Applause]
[Music]
oh [ __ ]
it came back yes
that's [ __ ] terrifying it's like a
goddamn lord of the rings orc in this
movie
come on come on come on come on
do it dude now this is as far as you go
no more
[Music]
[Music]
this is such a cool movie
oh you feel like a cathartic release
right there i don't think i've ever
rooted for a character this much in a
predator franchise like not not one
character i've ever like come on do i
kill
[Music]
i'm a hunter
we need to move to easier protected
ground is that the predator 2 gun i
thought that was a
different gun over my right half is it
the predator too good
[Music]
my god historical fiction at its finest
[Music]
i'm alive
[ __ ] yeah we got a great ass predator
movie
not since the first one we finally got a
great predator movie
holy crap
that was great that was really great
holy god i just
this franchise been so up and down and
we finally got a great ass predator film
i was so happy with that man that was
amazing like how they're doing the end
credits designs a lot making its way in
history this is how the story will be
told the cast was so good too oh god i
can't wait to talk about this like with
others and stuff i can't wait to share
the enthusiasm for this film
is that a setup for live more coming
the comanche nation
booyah
such great music too ah
ah
it's pumped it feels so good
to truly have a great predator film
again
and so
like obviously it pays pays like clear
tribute to things in the first movie but
i love how it feels like so different in
many many many ways other than the
predictable like oh we're gonna go to
the finale arc uh showdown which is
one-on-one setting up the trappings i
really love the immediacy of it that was
uh
that was great it was great great art
direction too all right let's talk about
it people all right as much as i said
that thing at the beginning about like
you know hey just because i'm going to
interview
talent
involved with the film doesn't mean i'm
gonna
you know be shy of criticizing
a movie if i don't like it
give examples at the beginning of this
video
to show like
i'm willing to do it
but now i'm
gotta be honest with you guys i i'm i'm
just excited to do the interviews now
because
that was
amazing who am i
oh [ __ ] i'm interviewing the main people
that made them two main characters i
didn't realize that
they never give us the leads
hell yeah
oh
sweet
okay um wow where to begin that was just
like solid it was solid it's like crisp
it's tight it's tense
it's exciting it's atmospheric
it's dreadful but it's got this great
rhythm
to it throughout it's like pulsating you
know like the the use of the drums uh
throughout with the with like the
kind of like tribal music
i thought just really played on the
heart so well and added to the intensity
of the film throughout and this
character
am i trying too hard
am i trying too hard the actress's name
amber
mid
thunder wow what a cool name
holy christ um damn amber mid thunder
what a name like that wow anywho
just redefining what the name amber
means
but um yeah the uh her character
i was so invested in from the very
beginning of this story
because it's it's so multi-layered with
her performance of how
she's someone
who obviously has like a lot of fear
there's already a lot of compounding
weight placed against her from just the
conditions of what she's grown up with
of the the with a societal point of view
within her her tribe her family of
telling her who she really can be and
what she's trying to be she just plain
and simple shouldn't so you do have that
investment in her of you want to watch
her rise and become the ultimate hunter
warrior and that was kind of the the
whole mood and vibe
of this entire film was like that primal
feeling of hunter warrior it made it
feel more visceral because this this
film is so
immediate and and while being so
tense and taught it it was one of those
like character driven performances
not through like getting a bunch of
exposition or monologuing or something
like that or just having like a butt
like it was just enough scenes to
establish it but really you're watching
the growth of this person arc into you
know utilizing their strengths
by to the end of the film and i like how
like the the death of her brother
is the catapult into her
getting to the like i don't give a [ __ ]
point and like it creates kind of this
this hardness within her
and that's like the final step in her
growth to be able to take on
the ultimate enemy which is his predator
and i thought the way the predator was
used felt so cool you know like the
predator at times
you know like don't get me wrong like i
i actually have a soft spot for uh most
of the predator films uh even like the
first alien versus predator film i have
a soft spot for i like predator too i i
really grew up watching both predator 1
and predator 2
constantly it was just a constant in my
household a film that maybe a little kid
shouldn't be watching but i was obsessed
with them
i really loved them and i even liked the
robert rodriguez film predators but this
easily
easily
like i don't i wouldn't want to declare
it as the best predator film out of the
whole franchise there are things about
it right away
mood wise that just draw to my
sensibilities and my my personal tastes
so much stronger than even the first
original john mctiernan predator film
but i can't like confidently sit here
and as easily establish like this is the
best predator movie
but
i can definitely say this is the best
predator movie since the original
and you know it's kind of this
conflicting feeling because because of
the fact that it's going to hulu i gotta
watch a screener and you know i get a
chance to share my reaction with you
guys so yeah there's that benefit but
this is like how many
how many films that have disappointed
fans uh in the predator move franchise
have gone to the theaters
and and this one is not getting that
which which is such a bummer because
there's so many great things from just a
filmmaking technical standpoint like the
cinematography doesn't feel quite
necessarily to the same like the level
of the revenant which was all like
natural lighting
we just use natural lighting but it
really does capture the reflective
lighting of the environment really using
the surfaces it has really using the
weather using those conditions and the
cinematography which was excellent like
the color palette was great it was
really visually striking throughout
and this the set designs and the
costumes like the overall art production
was was amazing uh really brought it to
life and like i'm i'm i'm a dummy who
doesn't know enough about
like
comanche history i don't know anything
about it all right i don't know jack
about it and and so and like my american
history is already like a little bit
muddied uh enough as it is so i i don't
really i'm not a historian in here to to
talk with you guys however i do get the
sense that they at least like uh
aiming to honor you know uh the native
american tribe
that i i get that sense to say the least
and because you get the you really get
the vibe in the culture sense
bottom line is like there was a cultural
sense throughout this whole film that
was constantly permeating uh for
beginning to end
with each one of these characters that
felt very lived in in that regard and
that's a big part of why i thought it
was so effective and emotionally
effective because while it's like the
only characters i really care about
are the two main characters the brother
and the sister
um that was just enough for a film that
is
as as tight as this
where it's like it's it's weird because
you're like you have the you have the
the forest you have the wilderness you
have the nature you got the waterfalls
you got everything at the river yet it
still felt very
contained i love the immediacy and the
buildup of it throughout and regarding
the predator the predator i know some of
this i said like during my reaction so
excuse me if i repeat myself from time
to time
there were parts of this predator that i
did find more ferocious
uh it it kind of had the sense of like a
hard r rated version of whatever that
main orc was in the fellowship of the
ring but this this
you know creature definitely
a lot smarter more more clever more coy
and more tactile obviously not just some
rampaging beasts but you kind of get the
qualities of both you get the qualities
of the skillful hunter but something
that does feel more beast-like
and more ruthless uh throughout and i
like i like the performance of whoever
played the predator because you do feel
like part that's part of what makes the
predator even more eerie is despite how
foreign it is
and you know like it's such a creature
such a sci-fi creature yet because of
its humanoid qualities
that's a big part of what makes the
creature so unsettling and i thought
that was really brought back here and
that's something that's kind of been
missing you know like i think a lot of
the time with these predator films they
try like while you have your your little
line homages and and some structural
things and and certain moments that are
clearly harkening back to the original
predator film
it it was really doing its own thing and
embodying the time period and the
environment that this this encapsulated
because this also did have that backdrop
and mood of films kind of like the edge
and revenant which uh have that you know
man versus nature quality and i like
that that was very much utilized
throughout this film as well because
because the the the feel of the game of
the hunt you know and and establishing
the groundwork like when she gets
trapped in the
is that quicksand
whatever that mud is that she's slowly
slowly fall into
and you know some things become a little
bit predictable like when they say the
blood is gonna make you
make your blood cold like okay she's
gonna be able to use that
um you know and certain certain things
that they would clearly
let's focus on this because we're gonna
definitely be using this later on in the
movie pay close attention to that uh i
thought was cool and i like it's like
video game qualities at times it does
feel like a level at times with the the
pov of fighting in the wilderness uh it
does feel like a survival horror game
and that's another theme that it really
captures strongly of that or or the the
mood the the feel such a survival horror
movie as well
and uh and even like the girl
the nauru's character this dog whatever
the dog's name is it did kind of feel
like that dog helper friend in a video
game and it always made me afraid that
they were gonna kill that dog uh man i
gotta warn some people because i know a
lot of people who can't watch movies if
there's if there's like a really if
there's like one harsh animal death but
there's like this many like there's no
way they can handle this and uh yeah
because like i was andrew gordon watch
this with me and uh he's he's like this
out of all my friends he's usually the
biggest predator fan but because of the
fact that i got the vid right now i was
like you you shouldn't be next to me and
uh
i'm glad he wasn't here because this was
this is brutal in that and i liked
seeing those early stages of the
predator like coming to earth and being
like what's the ultimate warrior here
and you know you have back then the
humans as hunters uh they
this was their prey this is who they
this is what they hunted these these
types of animals these threats and so
when you have the predator plop down
here and the predator is now hunting
what the humans hunt and it's just a
walk in the park for the predator it's
like nothing so easy
um
except for the bear i like that
and i like the perspective captures
that uh dan trachtenberg was able to to
do
with certain moments of like you you
could just get that kind of
exciteful filmmaker sense of of like man
if i did a predator movie this is kind
of the cool things i'd want to do like
with the bleeding bear encompassing the
camouflage stealth mode version of the
predator and that's the thing that
starts to illuminate you know outline
what the predator is but it's all like
scuzzy and messed up and i loved it i
loved it i love uh that this was like a
hard r that it took itself very serious
uh the brother too
uh dakota beavers top tabby tabby you
know you watch a whole movie you still
can't remember a character's name i i
liked uh how
authentic and sincere and uh sympathetic
the the portrayal of the ultimate
warrior in the tribe
uh was you know and as being this force
that helps motivate two you know and
he also was multi-layered because
obviously he loves his sister and he
wants to protect her and
he wants to be there for her and support
her and show this you know show love you
know be the ultimate brother
but
clearly he he has his doubts as well and
he he fights against it and i like that
you got the sense of again
three-dimensional characters
and and even giving some
path it's not something that pathos but
yeah some some weight to to the mom
uh
as well you know like while she can be
you know selling a little bit harsh at
times too that's our main lead uh you
know there there's there's such emotion
behind her portrayal as well like i
thought the cast was great
the the violence and the action was
really well choreographed and really
cool i loved a lot of the tracking shots
i liked that you could see what the hell
was going on even at times when i was
like okay we're going into dark
environment territory is this where we
try to mask some [ __ ] that they couldn't
quite do but no it it would always
provide a better like a more definitive
mood depending on whatever the sequence
was and i and i thought the action was
like packed a punch it was gory it was
cool to look at there was some awesome
stylish choreography throughout some
worthwhile kills um
yeah
this was the [ __ ] i thought this film
was awesome then the original score was
great
i i did i don't really i guess if i had
like one quan but but it really subsided
uh pretty early on for me like other
than the fact that like some things are
a little bit predictable but as a fan of
the predator franchise those are just
kind of tropes and motifs that i'd
expect when you got a story like this
you know i'm not expecting it to
completely
redefine cinema here i'm not expecting
it to
like do some type of like elevated
meditative like thought process of a
film but it does kind of you know
capture a little bit more of that
stimuli more than most of these predator
films man and
uh uh i totally lost my train of thought
here oh yes the
the
were they were they french they seem
like french clonius or settlers right
they they they see they seem
french um i don't know about the history
i don't i don't i was like spanish or
french i don't speak either language
seem french
um
regardless with those characters who
showed up
i
i i guess i i would have liked a little
bit if there was anything more to like
add a you know a little bit more run
time to the movie for it would have been
to kind of settle in with them
and not not that i was like i want to
get to know them and really care about
them that wasn't the case you know in
some ways it did feel like they were
set up here so that way they could be
uh you know
extra body counts
but
it and the reason i'm saying that is
because
you know by the time you meet them you
barely spend any time and then the next
you know a lot of them are getting you
know you know uh getting killed off uh
and and to me i was like ah maybe there
should have been something that kind of
and maybe there was a line of dialogue
that i that i missed i'm gonna give the
movie the benefit the downer you guys
clarify for me if there was something
there that i missed that established
that
you know other than the first shadowing
of the buffalo bean skin where we
thought it was the predator that was
doing it um other than that
it i thought there that could might have
been
used a little bit of like foreshadowing
that she would encounter uh these people
if they were aware of these people who
were out there um some little extra
focus on that because it did kind of
come in so late and the next thing you
know a lot of them are getting killed
off
however
this film is captured so much
solely from the perspective
of nauru
i think that's always her name
whatever i'm going with that
of nauru that well yeah in this person's
perspective
in this situation it's not like they're
getting foreshadowing in their life
they would just kind of stumble into the
situation i'm like okay so there's
actually a realistic touch to that that
i then began to appreciate
and
you know the the fun fanboy in me just
goes well [ __ ] you know like i thought
they at least
packed a presence in the sense of like
ruthless [ __ ] who shouldn't be here
and are here doing harmful [ __ ] uh i i
thought they packed that presence
and it just was rewarding to watch them
get killed off and yeah it leads to her
getting the gun and whatever i thought
it was still
very rewarding
and
would i have liked there's a little bit
more screen time with them maybe
but as it stands i still thought it was
effective when they were there i i
really i really enjoyed that prize so
yeah like
to me i think that's about the only
thing i might have a qualm with i don't
personally don't like that much animal
death in some of that
so cruel but if it works it really sets
you up for like oh my god this predator
i want to see this predator die and
that's another thing you know
like a lot of times with these predator
movies
it's been a long time since i was like i
want to see this predator die
and i really felt that like i was so
rooting for the main character that i'm
like yes kill the [ __ ] predator
and i'm just glad that this to finally
in this franchise again get back to
feeling that way because that's what you
want man the predator is the bad guy
like you gotta feel that way and it's
been a long time since i felt that way
and i i thought they brought back to a
real menacing scary imposing point again
uh yeah i i thought this was an
excellent film um
like
i would give it like a solid a at least
and i don't do great but here i am give
it like a solid a to say the least um as
a fanboy the predator franchise like
it's an a plus for sure this was
excellent excellent stuff
and yeah i'm actually kind of like
nervous to i gotta think of some good
questions because this was this was
awesome this was really really awesome
i i really loved it
yeah i love this one i'm i'm excited to
talk with people about it because this
was really cool and i hope you guys
enjoyed it too
uh but guys leave your thoughts down
below subscribe click that bell leave a
like subscribe to get accepted
no no no i say now subscribe to become a
citizen of the reject nation
much love people thank you for being
here